We covered the first three steps.
Next, we’ll talk about the feature selection
step. In the feature selection step, we have
talked about how construct features using
patient event sequences from the HRC data.
In particular, we construct feature
from raw data in the observation window.
If we look closely at the observation window, we
see event sequence data, which are corresponding
to different types of clinical events. For
example, diagnosis, symptoms, medications, patient
demographics, lab results, and vital signs. We
can construct features from all those events.
However, not all the events are relevant
for predicting a specific target. The
goal of feature selection is to find the truly
predictive features to be included in the model.
For example, here are two patient charts. We
can see some features such as demographics,
including age, race, and gender, and vital
signs such as blood pressures, and diagnosis
such as diabetes and hypertension. However, in
reality this patient chart is not that simple.
In fact, we can construct a long list
of features over 20,000 features,
from a typical EHR data set. Not all of
this are relevant for predicting a target.
We need to select the ones that are
relevant to the target condition.
For example, if we want to predict heart failure,
maybe those yellow features are relevant.
However, for a different condition, such as,
diabetes. Maybe those purple features are
relevant. The goal of features selections
is to identify those predictive features.